[संगीत]
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल
तो अब मुझे ओके सबसे पहले मुझे य बता द
सबको मेरी आवाज आ रही है नहीं आ रही सब
में तो कोई आया तो है नहीं वैसे लाइव
क्लास में थैंक यू वेरी मच लाइव क्लास में
नहीं आने के लिए और कोई
नहीं अब मुझे नहीं समझ में आता था कि टीचर
को कैसे मोटिवेशन मिलेगा कि इस तरीके से
वि देख के लाइव क्लास में कोई नहीं आया है
सब अकेला हूं और कोई नहीं है जस्ट वन एंड
टू प ओनली इ में से एक मेरे टीम मेंबर
होगा तो अब मुझे नहीं समझ में आता किस
तरीके से मैं मोटिवेट होके
आपको एक दिन छोड़ एक दिन आपको लेक्चर
डिलीवर कर दू और कैसे मैं कर दूं ऐसे कैसे
मोटिवेट रह सकता है कोई भी इंस्ट्रक्टर या
कोई भी टीचर आप लोगों के लिए मुझे तो य
चीज समझ में नहीं आती अगर आप लोग समझ में
आ आप लोग मुझे अच्छे से समझा सकते
हो मैं समझता हूं ठीक है कहीं अगर बिजी हो
जनन रीजन हो तो यही है बट हाल तो यही है
सभी
का तो प्लीज एक बार मुझे बता दीजिए यस या
नो अगर जो भी अवेलेबल है माय टीम मेंबर
आल्सो य सबको मेरी आवाज मेरी कोई आवाज आ
भी रही है नहीं आ रही है मैं वैसे ही बोले
जा रहा
हूं बस यस या नो बता
दीजिए
ओके थैंक यू
योगेश तो मैं काम करते हैं कि प्लीज मुझे
योगेश आपकी फर्स्ट डे क्लास है या सेकंड
डे है या पहले से कंटिन्यू करते आ रहे हो
मैं फर्स्ट टाइम देख रहा आपको क्लास में
प्लीज य बताइ आप फर्स्ट टाइम क्लास है या
इससे पहले भी मेरी क्लासे ंड कर चुके है
बस वाली
तो देखो लास्ट क्लास जो डे 16 थी उसम
मैंने वाइल लूप के बारे में आपको पढ़ाया
था वाइल लूप और साथ में गेट ऑप्स कमांड के
बारे में गेट ऑप्स कमांड के बारे में कि
अगर आप ऑप्शंस के साथ अपने स्क्रिप्ट को
बनाना चाहते हैं तो कैसे बना सकते हैं
जैसे आप ऑप्शंस यूज करते हैं बाकी कमांड
के साथ उस तरीके से आप अपने खुद के
स्क्रिप्ट भी बना सकते हैं वाय लूप आप
कैसे यूज कर सकते हैं मैंने ये बताया था
तो एक छोटा सा उसके बेस पर आगे बढ़ने से
पहले मैं क्या करूंगा आप लोगों को एक छोटा
सा उसका एक
अ छोटा सा लिटिल प्रोजेक्ट या बोल सकते
हैं छोटी सी स्क्रिप्ट रन करके दिखाऊंगा
स्क्रिप्ट बना के और रन करके दिखाऊंगा
ताकि आप लोगों का रिवीजन भी हो जाएगा और
मैंने ना उसके बेसिस पे जो मैं डे 16 में
जो भी पढ़ाया था मैंने उसका कंप्लीट नोट्स
मैंने बनाकर ग्रुप में शेयर कर दिया है
कंप्लीट नोट्स मैंने क्या किया है बनाया
और ग्रुप में शेयर कर दिया है और वोह
आर्टिकल मैंने खुद से लिखा है वो मीडियम
के ऊपर ताकि बाकी लोग भी पढ़ पाए तो जो भी
डे 16 में मैंने सब कु पढ़ाया है जो भी
डिटेल तो एक प्रकार से वो एक चीटशीट है
आपके लिए अगर आप रिवीजन करना चाहते हैं या
इन फ्यूचर कोई भी स्क्रिप्टिंग कर रहे हो
अगर आप स्कप लिखना चाहते हैं तो भी अगर आप
चाहते हो कि मुझे कोई रेफरेंस चाहिए
क्योंकि आप सभी लोग तो नोट्स नहीं बना
सकते ना सभी लोग नोट्स बना भी नहीं पाते
कुछ को आदत नहीं होती बस रेफर करने की
होती है तो इसलिए मैंने वो मेहनत आप लोगों
की लिख है और मैंने वहां पर वो मीडियम प
आर्टिकल्स राइट डाउन कर दिया तो आप सिंपली
क्या करना है कि आपको हमारे टेलीग्राम
ग्रुप में क्या किया मैंने उसको शेयर किया
था कुछ देर पहले शायद एक या एक घंटा पहले
या न ए हाफ वर एगो मैंने उसको क्या किया
हुआ शेयर किया हुआ आपके साथ तो आपको उसको
आसानी से क्या कर सकते हो रेफर कर सकते हो
साथ में अगर कुछ समझ में नहीं आता मेरी
वीडियो देख सकते हो फिर भी समझ में आता
मुझसे डाउट पूछ सकते हो तो मैं सबसे पहले
आपको क्या है कि एक छोटा सा प्रोजेक्ट बना
के दिखाऊंगा टाइमर एक टाइमर प्रोजेक्ट है
छोटा सा कि हम क्या कर टाइम कैसे हम अपने
वाइड लूप में टाइम कैसे कैलकुलेट कर सकते
हैं फर एपल आप कई बार कोई पेपर्स बना रहे
होते फ एपल मुझे क्या करना है बेस्ट स्कप
में कोई एक छोटा सा बस अ मुझे क्या है कि
बस खेलना है मुझे बेस्ट प्रैक्टिस करनी है
लॉजिक लगा के तो मैं एक लज बनाना चाहता कि
भैया ठीक है मैंने वहा पर मेंशन कर दिया
इतना टाइम बच गया अब इतना टाइम अब इतना
टाइम अब ना टाइम अपडेट हो रहा सेकंड बाय
सेकंड तो व कैसे बना सकते टाइम स्किप तो
मैं सबसे पहले क्या करता हूं एनो करता हूं
उसके बाद एक टाइमर डट एसस नाम से
आपके सामने बनाता हूं तो मैं क्या करता
हूं सिंग लाइन सिंग लाइन के बाद उसके बाद
य
रहा बिन बैस ब लाइन क्या होती है आप सबको
पता है य मेरी सी बैंग लाइन है बिन और बैस
नेक्स्ट क्या करता हूं मैं अभी वाल लूप का
यूज करूंगा अभी मैं क्या करूंगा वा वाल
लूप का यूज करने वाला हूं इल उसके बाद मैं
क्या करना गेट ऑ कमांड का यूज करने वाला
हूं क गेट ऑ कमांड का आपको बताया था कैसे
यूज करता और आपको आईडिया मिल गेट ऑप्स
कमांड उसके बाद ऑप्स आर्गुमेंट मतलब जो जो
ऑप्शंस मैं प्रोवाइड करना चाहता हूं अपने
यूजर को कि भैया मिनट और सेकंड खछ से
सिलेक्शन ले मिनट और सेकंड का ख से
सिलेक्शन ले ओके और ऊपर से एक और चीज क्या
चाहता हूं कि मैं जो भी ये आर्गुमेंट जो
भी ऑप्शंस देना चाहता हूं ऑप्शंस का
ऑप्शंस में मैं आर्गुमेंट लेना चाहता हूं
अब मैं इसको क्या है फिक्स नहीं रखना था
अपने लेवल पर मैं यूजर लेवल प यूजर के
हिसाब से इसको बना रहा हूं तो यूजर के
हिसाब से बना तो मुझे क्या करूंगा मैं जो
ऑप्शंस के आर्गुमेंट है मैं किससे लेना
चाहता हूं अपने यूजर से लेना चाहता हूं
मैं इसके लिए मैं मिनट और सेकंड मिनट और
सेकंड मर यूजर से लेना चाहता हूं तो मैं
ऐसे मेंशन करू एम एम फॉर मिनट टेस्ट फॉर
सेकंड के लिए मैं यूज करने वाला हूं इसके
बाद मैंने ये कॉलन क्यों दिया ताकि मैं
यूजर से क्या ले पाऊं आर्गुमेंट देन उसके
बाद मुझे क्या करना पड़ेगा एक वेरिएबल का
नाम देना पड़ेगा फॉर एग्जांपल मैं वेरिएबल
का नाम यहां पर ऑप्ट दे देता हूं उसके बाद
सेमीकलन मतलब क्या है कि ये कंडीशन है क्
वा लूप भी कंडीशन के बेस पर काम करता है
लेकिन जरूरी नहीं कि यहां पर हम टेस्ट
कंडीशन नहीं देंगे हम कोई भी कंडीशन दे
सकते हैं कोई भी कमांड कंडीशन दे सकते कुछ
भी दे सकते हैं गेट ऑप्स उसके बाद दो
ऑप्शन प्रोवाइड कर रहा हूं देन ऑट इस
वेरिएबल के अंदर आके इनका जो भी वैल्यू
स्टोर हो जाएगी डू देन डू मतलब अब लॉजिक
लगा रहा हूं डू के बाद मैं क्या कर रहा
हूं अभी डन डन क्यों कर रहा मैं इसको
क्लोज भी कर रहा हूं अब जो भी कोड लिखूंगा
मैं इसके अंदर लिखना चाहता हूं य रहा जो
भी कोड मैं लिखूंगा इसी के अंदर लिखना
चाहता हूं इसके अंदर लिखना चाहता हूं डू
और डन मतलब मैं इसके अंदर कमांड लिखना
चाहता हूं अब कमांड लिखने के लिए मैं क्या
करना चाहता हूं केस यूज करना चाहता हूं
मैं क्या यूज करूंगा केस क्योंकि मुझे
मल्टीपल ए के बेस पर मुझे केस बनाना है और
किसके बेस पे मुझे एस के केस प भी तो केस
और केस में क्या लेता हूं मैं वो ऑप्शन ये
रहा केस में लेता हूं किसके बेस पर केस
बनाता हूं केस में वेरिएबल का नाम लेता
हूं केस आपको पता है डॉलर उसके बाद ऑप्ट
दे रहा हूं उसके बाद ऑट पैरामीटर
एक्सपेंशन कर रहा हूं यहां पर और मैंने
आपको बताया था जब के स्टेटमेंट हम यूज कर
थे के स्टेटमेंट में डबल कोट प्लस में ये
डॉलर सिंबल देना जरूरी है क्योंकि य लेते
हैं उसके बाद इन आपको बताया मैंने केस को
कैसे यूज करते हैं नेक्स्ट अब केस को मुझे
क्लोज करना है केस को अगर मुझे क्लोज करना
कैसे कर सकते हैं इसक इसक करते हैं ई एस ए
स इसक करके हम क्या कर देते केस को क्लोज
कर देते हैं अभी मैं इसको क्या करता हूं
इधर स्पेस दिया ओके इधर चलो य अब मैं इसके
अंदर क्या करना चाहता हूं वो स्टेट केस
बनाना चाहता हूं जिसके ऊपर मेरा लॉजिक
परफॉर्म होगा तो पहला मेरा केस क्या है ए
उसके बाद केस वन है ए के लिए मैं केस
बनाना चाहता हूं उसके बाद केस वन देन ये
रहा क्योंकि ये क्लोज किया क्योंकि इसके
बाद हम क्या
करेंगे वो कमांड्स देना चाहते हैं जो हम
परफॉर्म करना चाहते हैं उससे पहले मैं
क्या चाहता हूं कि मैं एक वेरिएबल क्रिएट
करना चाहता हूं एक वेरिएबल टोटल क्योंकि
टाइम को मुझे कैलकुलेट करना है ना टोटल
सेकंड्स मैं सेकंड्स में कैलकुलेट करना
चाता हूं टोटल सेकंड्स इक्वल उसके बाद
मैंने इसको कर दिया एमटी अब यहां पर खाली
है भैया मुझे कैलकुलेट करना अभी मेरे पास
कुछ भी सेकंड जीरो अब मैं यहां पर क्या
करना चाहता हूं फिर टोटल देन एस इ सेकंड
टोटल सेकंड्स इक्वल अब मैं क्या चाता हूं
टोटल सेकंड इक्वल उसके बाद अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन यूज करना चाहता हूं अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन यूज करूंगा मैं अर्थमेटिक
एक्सपेंशन यूज करूंगा देन उसके बाद मैं
क्या करना चाहता हूं डॉलर
डॉलर टोटल उसके बाद क्या
है ओ एनडी एस टोटल सेकंड्स देन उसके बाद
मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं प्लस सिंबल प्लस
देन उसके बाद क्या करना चाहता हूं डॉलर और
ऑप्ट आर्ग ट आर्गुमेंट आ क्य यूज कर रहा
हूं क्योंकि यहां पर जो एम के साथ जो भी
आर्गुमेंट जो वैल्यू आएगी किसकी वैल्यू ए
के साथ जो भी हम पटर जो वैल्यू देंगे
आर्गुमेंट में ऑप्शन के साथ तो उसकी
वैल्यू आगे स्टोर ऑगमेंट में आ स्टोर हो
जाती है उसके बाद मल्टीप्लाई करना चाहता
हूं किसके साथ 60 क्योंकि मैं सेकंड में
कन्वर्ट करता ह अगर मिट दिया तो देन उसके
बाद मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं क्लोज करना
मेरे उसको अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन को देन डबल
ए क्योंकि ये मेरा पहला केस था अभी मैं
आपको समझा देता हूं यहां पर क्या किया
मैंने देखो टोटल सेकंड क्या थी ओके ओके
सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी देखो टोटल सेकंड मेरी
कितनी है अभी इसमें जीरो है कुछ भी नहीं
है देन अब मैं पहले केस क्या टोटल सेकंड
क्योंकि देखो मुझे इसमें वैल्यू स्टोर
करनी है इस वेरिएबल के अंदर इसके अंदर जो
भी वैल्यू बचेगी उसी को मैं कैलकुलेट
करूंगा और यहां पर मैं कैलकुलेट कर रहा
सेकंड में कैलकुलेट कर रहा तो सबसे पहले
टोटल सेकंड कितनी जितनी भी हो प्लस हो जाए
उसमें और अगर ऑट आर्गुमेंट में जितने भी
यूजर्स आपको मिनट दे रहा है व सेकंड के
साथ मल्टीप्लाई होके इसके अंदर ऐड हो जाए
नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट जो मेरा केस है वो मेरा
केस है सेकंड का सेकंड के केस में मैं
क्या करना चाहता हूं सेकंड उसके बाद उसके
अंदर मैंने क्या एक मिनट ये रहा
सेकंड
टोटल सेकंड्स उसके बाद इक्वल फिर से मैं
क्या करना चाहता हूं क्या यूज करूंगा
अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन अ क्या है ऑलरेडी ये
सेकंड है तो मैं क्या करना चाहूं
डॉलर
टोटल सेकंड्स देन उसके बाद मैं क्या चाता
हूं प्लस सिंबल अबके बाद डॉलर ऑप्ट
आर्गुमेंट डॉलर ओके डॉलर ऑप्ट ए
आरजी ऑप्ट आर्गुमेंट क्यों क्योंकि अ ये
सेकंड से मल्टीप्लाई क्यों नहीं क ऑलरेडी
ये सेकंड है ऑलरेडी ये सेकंड है तो अ इसके
इसको भी मैंने क्या कर दिया क्लोज कर दिया
इसको भी क्लोज कर दिया देन उसके बाद हो
गया बस ये दो कंडीशन है दो ऑप्शन के बेस
पर मुझे क्या करना चाहता था कि मैं ये दो
लॉजिक परफॉर्म करना चाहता हूं या दो कमांड
परफॉर्म करना चाहता हूं मतलब अगर एम
सेलेक्ट किया या एस सेलेक्ट किया तो मेरा
कितना बच
गया ओबवियसली देन अब मैं क्या करना चाहता
हूं ये तो मैंने क्या कर दिया एक वो लॉजिक
बनाया किसके ऊपर एम और एस के ऊपर अब मैं
एक वा ये तो वाइल लूप लगा के मैंने क्या
कर लिया किससे ले लिया यूजर से आउटपुट
लिया ए और मिनट और सेकंड मुझे एक और वाइल
लूप यूज करना होगा क्यों क्योंकि अब मुझे
इनको कैलकुलेट भी करना है ना भैया अब मुझे
इसको कैलकुलेट भी करना ना हर बार कैलकुलेट
करके आपको हमेशा अपडेट करना है और
कैलकुलेट करके अपडेट करना तो मुझे एक और
वाइ लूप यूज करना होगा उसके लिए मैं क्या
करूंगा वा लूप में भी क्या करना टेस्ट
स्टेटमेंट यूज करूंगा अगर अब क्या
डॉलर
टोटल सेकंड्स टोटल सेकंड्स
अगर ग्रेटर देन है जीरो से अगर वो ग्रेटर
देन जीरो है तब तक जीरो से अगर ग्रेटर देन
है तो तो मेरा वाइल लूप चलता रहे और मुझे
क्या एक्शन परफॉर्म करना है इसके बेस पर
बेस मुझे एक्शन परफॉर्म करना है एकको देन
डॉलर उसके बाद एकको
डॉलर टोटल
सेकंड टोटल सेकंड्स य पर मेरी जितनी बच गई
उसके बाद नेक्स्ट अब मैं क्या करना चाहता
हूं अब मुझे अगर मैंने यहां पर सेकंड की
वैल्यू को अगर कम नहीं किया तो ये
कैलकुलेट कर पाएगा इन फाइना लूप चला जाएगा
तो मुझे इन फाइट रोकने यहां पर टोटल
वैल्यू को मुझे क्या करना पड़ेगा कम करना
पड़ेगा तो अब मैं क्या करूंगा
टोटल सेकंड्स देन उसके बाद इक्वल फिर से
मैं डॉलर उसके बाद मैं क्या करना चाता हूं
फिर से अर्थमेटिक एक्सपेंशन डॉलर उसके
बाद
टोटल सेकंड्स और उसके
बाद माइनस क्योंकि हर बार मैंने एक एक कम
करना है ना इसमें से मुझे न माइनस व ये
रहा इतना कर दिया देन उसके बाद मुझे क्या
करना है अभय मुझे पता नहीं चलेगा मैं इसको
स्लिप करना हूं स्लिप फॉर न सेकंड स्लिप
फॉर वन सेकंड क्यों क्योंकि मुझे दिखना
चाहिए आउटपुट मेरा सही से चल रहा है देन
यह इसके बाद मैंने क्या कर दिया डन मुझे
एक और वा लूप मैंने कर दिया देन अब मैं
क्या कर रहा हूं एकको कर रहा हूं अगर मुझे
एकको क्यों किया अब पहला पहला वा लूप
चलेगा य पर ये कैलकुलेट करेगा कि यूजर्स
ने क्या आउटपुट दिया है य क्या यूजर से
इनपुट लेगा देन उसके बेस पर क्या करेगा
कैलकुलेशन करेगा हर बार आपको स्क्रीन प
आउटपुट शो करेगा इतनी सेकंड बच गी उसके
बाद जब सेकंड कंप्लीट होगी जीरो होगी क्या
हु एक टाइम अप आपको ये उसके बाद य क्या
दोनों काम कंप्लीट हो जाएगा ये दोनों लूप
का काम कंप्लीट हो जाएगा तब क्या होगा तब
ये स्टेटमेंट काम कर अदर वाइज क्या अगर
दोनों काम कंपलीट नहीं होगा तो नीचे वाली
स्टेटमेंट काम ही नहीं करेगी क्या टाइम्स
अप टाइम्स अप ओके टाइम्स अप तो ये
हमने एक छोटी स्क्रिप्ट बनाई और उसके बाद
मैं क्या करता हूं कंट्रोल एक्स करता हूं
उसके बाद मैं इसको परमिशन देता हूं सीच
मोड 744 उसके बाद टाइमर ड
एच टाइमर डट एस ओके इसको मैं क्या करता
हूं रन करता हूं टाइमर ड एस उसके बाद मैं
क्या करना चाहूं अब हान एम मिनट देना
चाहता हूं मिनट में कितने देना चाहता
हूं 30 30 मिनट देना चाहता हूं और ट एंटर
किया मैंने
देखो कमांड नोट फाउंड व्ट हैपन व्ट हैपन
व्ट हैपन कमान
टाइमर कंट्रोल एक्स इशू हो गया इशू हो गया
ू हो गया कंट्रोल सी एरर आई है इस को
सॉल्व करना ही पड़ेगा अय एरर कहां पर है
इसको देख रहा है लाइन नंबर
12 चलो हम इसको देखते
हैं फर 5 6
ओके
[संगीत]
एक ओके आना तो यही चाहिए व्हाट इज द इशू
व्ट
हैपन मुझे यह सही है सही
[संगीत]
है मुझे हमेशा क्या स्पेल मिस्टेक ज्यादा
होती है इसलिए वही देख रहा
हूं
म बाकी इ अगर मैं
इसको बिना इसके करता
हूं
एक काम मैं करता हूं इसमें इशू कमांड नॉट
फाउंड इधर दिखा रहा है इधर दिस इ द इशू
विद
ट इसको क्या करता
हूं
इधर
एन
के
ओ हो हो दिस इज द इशू ट्स वा द एरर दिस इज
द एरर कंट्रोल एस कंट्रोल एक्स नाउ इट्स
वर्किंग 39 20 ये इट्स वर्किंग नाउ इट्स
वर्किंग नाउ प्रॉब्लम इज दैट कि मैंने
यहां पर डॉलर यूज किया हुआ था मैंने यहां
पर डॉलर यूज किया था जो मुझे क्या वैल्यू
में वेरिएबल में सेव करना चाहता बाकी
प्रॉब्लम मेरी वही आ रही थी तो यह टाइपर
थी कोड में आप देखो बिल्कुल एटली ऐसे काम
जैसे करना चाहिए देखो मिनट के साथ यूज करो
सेकंड के साथ कैसे भी करो आप देखो 7 6 फ 4
टूवन टाइम अप ओके टाइम अप तो इस तरीके से
आप स्कप सक्सेसफुली काम कर रही है नो
इशू आपकी सक्सेसफुली काम कर रही है
ओके चलो फिर हम नेक्स्ट टॉपिक स्टार्ट
करते हैं कंटिन्यू मुझे पता है चैट में
कोई आता है कोई जाता है तो नेक्स्ट टॉपिक
आज मैं अभी बात करने वाला हूं इसी में एक
रीड वाइल लूप के बारे में पढ़ने वाले हैं
नेक्स्ट टॉपिक जो हम पढ़ने वाले है ना अभी
रीड वाइल लूप के बारे में बताने वाला हूं
आपको य स्क्रीन क्लियर कर देता हूं आपको
स्क्रीन के सामने अब मैं आपको बताता हूं
कौन सा टॉपिक पढ़ने वाला हूं रीड वाय लूप
रीड य इशू मेरे उसका
ल
क्लियर रीड वाय लूप देखो रीड वाइल लूप के
देखो क्या है ये कॉमिनेशन है किसका रीड
कमांड का और वाइल लूप का कॉमिनेशन है जो
आपको सिखाने वाला हूं और क्या करते हो आप
कब यूज करते हो रीड वाय लूप को रीड वायल
लूप को हम जब यूज करते हैं जब हमें किसी
फाइल से कंटेंट को रीड करना होता है लाइन
बाय लाइन या मतलब बेसिकली यही है ओनली मेन
पर्पस है कि अगर मुझे किसी भी फाइल से
लाइन बाय लाइन किसी भी कंटेंट को रीड करना
है और उसके बेसिस पर मुझे क्या करना है
टास्क परफॉर्म करवाने हैं उसके बेसिस पर
एक्शन लेने हैं या उसके बेस मुझे उसकी
सोर्टिंग करनी है या कुछ भी मुझे करना है
वो सारे काम रीड लूप के थ कर सकते काफी
हेल्पफुल होते हैं यह और काफी पावरफुल
एबिलिटी आपको प्रोवाइड करते हैं ताकि आप
क्या है किसी भी फाइल से उसके आउटपुट को
रीड कर पाओ लाइन बाय लाइन तो मैं आपको
दिखाता हूं एपल मैं एक काम करता हूं अभी
एक ननो करता हूं
और ननो उसके बाद फाइल डटी एक्सटी एक फाइल
क्रिएट करता हूं इसके अंदर लाइन लिखता
हूं दिस
इज लाइन
नंबर वन
01 दिस इज लाइन
नंबर
ट दिस
इज लाइन
नंबर लाइन नंबर 03 दिस लाइन नंबर 03 उसके
बाद है दिस
इज लाइन
नंबर लाइन
नंबर 04 ओके चार लाइन लिखे इसमें कंट्रोल
एस कंट्रोल एक्स करता हूं उसके बाद अब मैं
क्या करता हूं मुझे मैं इसको क्या करहा
हूं एक स्क्रिप्ट लिखना चाहता हूं इस फाइल
से हर एक लाइन को रीड करे और आपकी स्क्रीन
पर प्रिंट आउट करे तो मैं ननो उसके बाद
रीड वाइल डट एएच डॉट एसए नाम की स्क्रिप्ट
लिखना चाहता हूं तो मैं सबसे पहले से बैंग
लाइन यूज करूंगा से बैग लाइन उसके बाद बिन
और बेस बिन और बेस उसके बाद मैं क्या करता
हूं सबसे पहले रीड वाल यूज करना सबसे पहले
यूज करने वाले हैं वाइल लूप तो वाइल उसके
बाद देखो आपको पता है आप सबको पता है कि
हम वाइल के साथ ओनली टेस्ट कमांड ही नहीं
बल्कि हम कुछ भी यूज कर सकते हैं तो अभी
मैं क्या करने वाला हूं रीड कमांड को यूज
करने वाला हूं वाइल के साथ मैं क्या करने
वाला हूं रीड कमांड को यूज करने वाला हूं
उसके बाद मैंने क्या रीड किया देन उसके
बाद मैंने क्या एक वेरिएबल का नाम यहां पर
मैंने लाइन दिया वेरिएबल का नाम एल आई एन
ई लाइन वेरिएबल का नाम उसके बाद मेरी
कंडीशन कंप्लीट होगी जैसे मेरी कंडीशन
कंप्लीट होगई उसके बाद मैं डू देन उसके
बाद डन कर देता हूं देन अभी इसके अंदर
मुझे क्या करना है इसके बेसिस पर क्या
करना है आपको कमांड लिखनी है जो मैं
परफॉर्म करना चाहता हूं जो भी मैं परफॉर्म
करना चाहता हूं लेकिन मुझे उससे पहले एक
और काम करना है क्या करना है कि सबसे
इंपोर्टेंट चीज की
मुझे वह फाइल रीड करवानी है मुझे वह फाइल
रीड करवानी है तो फाइल को मैं कैसे रीड
करवा सकता हूं मैं उस फाइल को एक तो रीड
करवा सकता हूं उसका फुल पाथ देके उसका फुल
एब्सलूट पाथ देके उस फाइल को रीड करवा
सकता हूं अगर मेरी फाइल फिक्स है तो अगर
मेरी फाइल कोई भी रैंडम फाइल हो सकती है
कभी भी कोई भी चेंज कर सकते हो डायनेमिक
फाइल है मन किया कोई भी फाइल आप यूज कर
सकते हो तो उस केस में हम यहां पर यूज
करेंगे किस चीज का पोजीशन पैरामीटर्स का
इस केस में हम क्या करेंगे पोजीशन
पैरामीटर्स का हम क्या करेंगे हम अपनी
उसमें स्क्रिप्ट में स्क्रिप्ट के साथ
फाइल का नाम देंगे और यह ऑटोमेटिक उसको को
क्या कर
लेगा रीड कर लेगा तो मुझे अगर ऐसा करना तो
मुझे क्या करना पड़े डन के बाद इनपुट
रीडायरेक्शन करना होगा आउटपुट रीडायरेक्शन
इनपुट रीडायरेक्शन उसके बाद ये यहां पर
डॉलर वन यहां पर डॉलर वन डॉलर वन क्यों
दिया फर्स्ट आर्गुमेंट पर फर्स्ट पोजीशन
पैरामीटर्स पे पर जो भी वैल्यू जो भी फाइल
का नाम दिया गया ये उसको रीड करेगा फर्स्ट
पोजीशन पैरामीटर्स पर या कमांड लाइन
आर्गुमेंट जो सबसे पहला होगा उसको उसपे जो
आप क्या करो स्क्रिप्ट के साथ दोगे तो उस
वहां पर आप क्या करोगे फाइल दोगे तो आपको
क्या करना है जैसे आप फाइल दोगे उसको ये
रीड करेगा और ये वन बा वन रीड करेगा यहां
से ये इनपुट रीडायरेक्शन मतलब यहां पर वो
फाइल आएगी फि ये किसको इनपुट देगा इसको
वाइल लूप को ये वाइल लूप को इनपुट देगा
देन ये रीड करेगा रीड कमांड का काम क्या
है कमांड से रीड करना अब ये क्या वायल लूप
से रीड करेगा इस इस वेरिएबल के अंदर
वैल्यू स्टोर करेगा उसका टास्क परफॉर्म
करेगा और ऐसे ही लूपिंग करेगा अब मैं क्या
करना चाहता हूं मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं
इधर इसके बेसिस पर परफॉर्म करना चाहता हूं
एकको देन मैं इसके बाद इसका आउटपुट ही शो
करना चाहता हूं एकको और डॉलर लाइन डॉलर
लाइन देखो आपको खुद ही पता चल जाएगा कि
काम कैसे कर रहा है अब कंट्रोल एस कंट्रोल
एक्स देन मैं क्या कर रहा हूं आपको अभी
सीच मोड देन 744 परमिशन के ऊपर मेंशन करता
हूं उसके बाद ड वाइल ड एएच उसके बाद ये
करता है डवाल ड
ए और फाइल का नाम फाइल का फाइल
एक्स य पर फुल पाथ मेंशन करूंगा य पर
मेंशन करू वहा पर य कोई भी फाइल दे सकता
हूं उसको रीड करेगा देखो दिस लाइन नंबर वन
लाइन नंबर टू लाइन नंबर थ एक साथ इसने रीड
कर दिया चलो अगर आपको समझ में इसने कैसे
रीड किया ज्यादा फास्ट हो गया तो इसम क्या
करता हूं स्लिप कर देता हूं स्लिप न सेकंड
या ट सेकंड देखो मैं क्या करता हूं फिर से
मैं लिप फॉर ू सेकंड दो सेकंड स्लिप करेगा
कंट्रोल एस कंट्रोल एक्स देन इसके बाद य
देखिए
ू लाइन नंबर थ्री लाइन नंबर फोर इस तरीके
से क्या कर रहा है ये आपका रीड वाइल लूप
काम कर रहा है अब एक और चीज है कि आप
चाहते हो कि नहीं मैं फाइल से आउटपुट अपना
क्या नहीं करवाना चाहता मैं जो फाइल है
उसको रीड नहीं करवाना लाइन बाय लाइन मैं
तो किसी कमांड के आउटपुट को रीड करवाना
चाहता हूं मैं किसी कमांड के आउटपुट को
रीड करवाना चाहता हूं तो वो मैं कैसे कर
सकता हूं तो वो करने के लिए मुझे क्या
करना पड़ेगा
यहां पर
मुझे प्रोसेस सब्सीट्यूशन करना पड़ेगा
क्या करना पड़ेगा प्रोसेस सब्सीट्यूशन
प्रोसेस सब्सीट्यूशन क्या होता है कि किसी
भी लिनक्स में या किसी भी यूनिक्स ड्राइव
सिस्टम जो यूनिक्स ड्राइड सिस्टम है सब
में प्रोसेस सब्सीट्यूशन काम करती है
प्रोसेस सब्सीट्यूशन क्या होता है कि कोई
भी जर्निंग प्रोसेसेस है उसको एज ए फाइल
रिप्रेजेंट करती है और रीड वायल लूप में
क्या कंडीशन है कि रीड वायल लूप ओनली
फाइल्स को ही लाइन बाय लाइन रीड करता है
इसके अलावा किसी चीज को वो लाइन बाय लाइन
रीड नहीं करता है तो अगर मुझे किसी भी
कमांड के आउटपुट को रीड करवाना है लाइन
बाय लाइन तो मुझे क्या करना पड़ेगा उसको
एज ए फाइल मेंशन करना पड़ेगा एज ए फाइल
देना पड़ेगा और आपको पता है कोई भी कमांड
आप अपनी मशीन में रन करते हैं तो क्या
है ये क्या है कि वो एज ए प्रोसेस काउंट
होती है क्योंकि वो भी एक प्रोसेस है और
अब मैं अगर प्रोसेस के ऊपर प्रोसेस
सब्सीट्यूशन करता हूं तो क्या करेगा वो
उसको एज ए फाइल रिप्रेजेंट करेगा और जब एक
फाइल रिप्रेजेंट होगी तो अग उस फाइल को हम
अगर इसमें मेंशन करेंगे विल रीड वाइल रूप
में तो क्या करें उसको लाइन बाय लाइन उसके
आउटपुट को रीड करेगा तो मैं इसको कैसे
करता हूं अगर कमांड से मुझे वो करना है तो
आउटपुट लेना है तो मैं य करूंगा डॉलर वन
की जगह मैं यहां क्या मेंशन करूंगा सिंपली
प्रोसेस सब्सीट्यूशन प्रोसेस सब्सीट्यूशन
कैसे करते हैं आपको मैं बता देता हूं
प्रोसेस सब्सीट्यूशन करने के लिए हम क्या
करते हैं यहां पर एक को डायरेक्शन सिंबल
देन यहां पर ये ब्रैकेट इसके अंदर मैं
मेंशन करूंगा कमांड इसके अंदर मैं मेंशन
करूंगा एलस देन मुझे डॉलर होम मेंशन किया
मैंने यहां पर डॉलर होम मेंशन किया अगर
मैं अब इसको क्या करता हूं कंट्रोल एस और
एक्स अब मैं इसको आपको रन करके दिखाता हूं
यहां पर यह रहा अब मैं कुछ नहीं कर सिंपली
इसको रन कर रहा हूं हिट एंटर
देखो डलर होम के अंदर क्याक थे क्या क्या
डायरेक्टरी थी यह क्या आ गया डेस्कटॉप
डॉक्यूमेंट डाउनलोडस म्यूजिक पिक्चर्स
ऑटोमेटिक कितनी अच्छी ब्यूटी है कि देखो
प्रोसेस सब्सीट्यूशन क्या कर रहा है किसी
भी प्रोसेस को एज ए फाइल आपको बता रहा है
रिप्रेजेंट कर दिया जब ए फाइल रिप्रेजेंट
कर दिया इसने क्या कर दिया
उसको सिंपली रीड करना शुरू कर दिया रीड
वाले ने लाइन बाय लाइन अगर ऐसा नहीं करना
देखो आप ऐसे भी कर सकते हो फॉर एग्जांपल
मैंने कि एल एस हान एल ए कर सकता हूं व भी
मैं करूंगा तो आपको ऐसे दिख जाएगा अगर हाइ
फन एल ए करता हूं देन अगर मैं कंट्रोल एस
कंट्रोल एक्स करता हूं तब भी आप देखिए ये
रहा टोटल 130 लाइन बाय लाइन सारे आउटपुट
को शो करेगा लाइन बाय लाइन जो आप एक कमांड
में देखने को मिलते है ये लाइन बाय लाइन
सारे आउटपुट को आपकी स्क्रीन के सामने शो
करेगा अब कई बार क्या होता है कि कोई भी
बिगिनर्स है सबसे ज्यादा गलतिया एक और
करते हैं मैं दिखाता हूं कि वो गलती क्या
करते है मैं इसको अगर एक बार चलने देता
हूं तो ठीक है नहीं तो मैं इसका क्या कर
देता हूं कंट्रोल सी कर देता हूं इंटरप्ट
कर देता हूं अब आप लोग क्या करते हैं
स्टार्टिंग में बोला सर मुझे समझ में आ
गया ड वा लू आप क्या करो बोला यार ये तो
काम मैं ऐसे भी कर सकता हूं ना फॉर
एग्जांपल मैंने यहां पर क्या किया था एज
फाइल चाया था अभी मैं इसको क्या करर चलो
ऐसे कर दिया तो मैं अगर मैं जो चीज यहां
पर दे रहा था ऐसे कि फाइल का नाम उसके बाद
डॉलर और वन मैंने फाइल कर ये तो मैं ऐसे
भी कर सकता हूं इसको इनपुट डायरेक्शन यहां
से मैं सिंपली क्या किया कट कर दिया तो
मैं ऐसे भी कर सकता हूं सर काम तो वही
करना चाहिए ना रीड लाइन ये रीड कर रहा है
मैं इसको इस को दे देता हूं ना तो लो
इनपुट डायरेक्शन य इसको दे देता हूं इनपुट
रीडायरेक्शन उसके बाद ये देन डॉलर और वन
सिंपली सर ये तो मैंने इसको भी कर दिया
काम तो यही करना चाहिए देखो सर आपने इधर
दिया तो इसने क्या कर दिया ये रीड वाइल
लूप इसको रीड कर लाइन बा लाइन अगर मैं ऐसा
करता तो क्या होगा तो मैं आपको दिखाता हूं
ऐसा करने से क्या होगा देखो ये
रहा ये रहा ट एंटर देखो लाइन नंबर वन लाइन
नंबर वन लाइन नंबर वन यह चलता ही रहेगा
चलता ही रहेगा चलता ही रहेगा य रुकेगा ही
नहीं एक्चुअल में हमने क्या किया ना हमें
क्या करना था यहां पर मिस्टेक हमारी यह
हुई कि हमें जो भी जो सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट
लेसन हमारे यहां पर क्या है कि हमें जो
स्टैंडर्ड इनपुट था ना वह हमें वाइल लूप
को देने की बजाय हमने रीड कमांड को दे
दिया तो स्टैंडर्ड रीड कमांड में क्या है
ओनली दिस इज लाइन नंबर वन है स्टैंडर्ड इट
क्योंकि लूपिंग हुई ही नहीं फाइल के ऊपर
रीड कमान ने क्या किया फाइल का सबसे पहला
जो वर्ड था या सबसे पहली लाइन थी उसको
क्या कर दिया उसने रीड किया उसको क्या
किया इसने रीड किया दिखाता आपको मैं आप रा
आपने यहां पर जो डॉलर वन में फाइल न फाइल
एक्सटी है उसके अंदर सबसे पहली लाइन क्या
है दिस इ लाइन नंबर वन और आपने किसको
इनपुट रीडायरेक्शन दिया स्टैंडर्ड इसी को
रीड कमांड इसी को दिया आपने रीड कमांड को
तो यहां पर आया क्या है ओनली
क्या आया है दिस इज लाइन नंबर वन य हमेशा
ट्रू है इसलिए इनफा चला गया कोई फायदा ही
नहीं क्योंकि मुझे जो स्टैंडर्ड इनपुट
रीडायरेक्शन देना था वो किसको वाइल लूप को
देना था ना कि रीड कमांड को और आपने क्या
किया यहां पर रीड कमांड को इनपुट
रीडायरेक्शन दे दिया जिसकी वजह से क्या
किया कि यहां पर तो सही है काम कर रहा है
बट यह क्या है कि अब लकिंग लूपिंग कंप्लीट
कैसे होगी नेक्स्ट लाइन आएगी ही नहीं
क्योंकि ये फर्स्ट लाइन ही रीड कर रहा ओली
इसके ऊपर कोई लूपिंग नहीं है ना क्योंकि
इसके अंदर रिप्लेस हुआ फाइल डटी एक्सटी
फाने रीड किया एक ही वेरिएबल है अब यहां
से टर्न कैसे करेगा य तो फाइल नंबर वन ही
है लेकिन जब आप लूपिंग किसको देते हैं अगर
आपको वाइल को दे हु जब वाइल जो है लूप है
वाइल लूप को आप प्रोवाइड करोगे स्टैंडर्ड
इनपुट तो वाइल लूप रीड कर रहा है फाइल को
फाइल डटी एक्सटी को वाल लूप रीड कर रहा है
दिस इज लाइन नंबर वन ओके उसने फिर रीड
कमांड को रीड कमांड उसको रीड किया इसके
अंदर सेव किया इसने प्रिंट कर उसके बाद
नेक्स्ट लाइन नंबर टू लाइन नंबर थ्री लाइन
नंबर फोर तो प्लीज ये गलती ना करें अदर
वाइज क्या है बिगनर के साथ होता है
क्योंकि देखो उन्ह लगता है यार देखो जो
काम वहां कर सकता हूं य भी कर सकता हूं
देखो गलत नहीं है बट जैसा आपको आउटपुट
चाहिए वैसा आपको देखने को नहीं
मिलेगा ओके तो यह आपका जो टॉपिक था कौन सा
रीड वाइल लूप का आपको समझ में आ गया होगा
अगर एक छोटा से इसके ऊपर एक असाइनमेंट
करके दिखाता हूं आपको ड ए के ऊपर ही क्या
है कि मैंने अभी यह रहा एक फाटी ना इसको
मैं एडिट कर देता हूं इसके अंदर मैं मेंशन
करता हूं फाटी एक्सटी यह रहाय ये रहा नो
इसके अंदर मैं मेंशन कर देता हूं
कुछ फोल्डर्स के नाम मैं क्या करना मेरे
पास कुछ नहीं है फॉर एपल अभी तो मैं 4 टू
सि फोल्डर ले रहा हूं लेकिन मैं ताता हूं
कि यहां पर कोई भी नेटवर्क के ऊपर काम कर
रहा हूं और मुझे क्या करना है कि अपनी
मशीन में बाय डिफॉल्ट या 200 या 50 या 20
फोल्डर एक साथ क्रिएट करने है डायरेक्ट एक
साथ क्रिएट करनी है तो भैया हर बार मशीन
को ओपन वन बा वन थ नहीं करूंगा ब
स्क्रिप्ट लिख सकता हूं कैसे कर सकता हूं
देखो य पर पहले मैंने लिखा की हेलो वर्ल्ड
हेलो वर्ल्ड हेलो वर्ल्ड करके मैंने फड
बना रहा उसके बाद मैं लिखा य पर कि सचिन
नाम का एक बन जाए देन उसके बाद एक बन
जाए नितेश सिंह
नितेश सिंह उसके बाद अगर यहां पर उसके बाद
बन जाए एक डे
फोनिक्स फोनिक्स से बन जाए नेक्स्ट उसके
बाद क्या है ए सी ए डीई एम अकेडमी
सोल्यूशन के नाम से बन जाए तो बस इतना ही
चाहता हूं तो कंट्रोल एस कंट्रोल एक्स अब
मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं स्क्रिप्ट लिखना
चाहता हूं इसके लिए तो चलो
ड अभी मैं यहां पर क्या करता हूं इसको
क्लोज कर देता बिल्कुल ये रहा बस उसके बाद
मैं क्या करहा
वाइल उसके बाद रीड किया मैंने देन उसके
बाद लाइन किया क्यक लाइन अभी मैं क्या
करना लाइन ही कर रहा हं उसके बाद डू देन
उसके बाद डन कर दिया मैंने अब इसके अंदर
मैं क्या करूंगा कोड लिखूंगा कौन सा कोड
जो
आपके डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट करेगा अब मुझे
डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट करना तो एम के डी आई आर
एम केडी आई उसे अब मुझे क्या करना है
मैंने क्या किया डॉलर उसके बाद लाइन किया
अब मुझे डॉलर लाइन उसके बाद सिंपली यहां
पर मैं क्या कर कर दिया ये रहा ग्रेटर देन
सिंबल और डबल कोट और
डॉलर वन दे दिया यहां पर अब बस इतनी सी
स्क्रिप्ट है तो मुझे यह बताइए कि क्या
मैंने यह सही लिखा है क्या मैंने यह सही
लिखा है मुझे मैंने सही नहीं लिखा क्योंकि
मुझे इसको क्या करना है डबल कोट के अंदर
रैप करना था क्योंकि मेरे साथ बहुत सारे
ऐसे फाइल डटी एक्सटी के अंदर कुछ ऐसे
नाम्स हैं जो स्पेस सेपरेटेड है अगर स्पेस
सेपरेटेड है तो वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग परफॉर्म
होगी तो सबको अलग-अलग डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट
कर देगा जैसे नितेश सिंह नितेश सिंह को
अगर मुझे एक साथ डायरेक्टरी क्रिएट करवानी
है तो मुझे क्या करना पड़ेगा इस वर्ड
स्प्लिटिंग से रोकना होगा वर्ड स्प्लिटिंग
से रोकने के लिए हम डबल कोट का यूज करते
हैं सिंपली कंट्रोल एस कंट्रोल एक्स अब
मैं क्या कर रहा हूं इसको परमिशन है मेरे
पास अब मैं क्या करता हूं इसको ड फाइल
डॉट इससे पहले मैं काम करता हूं आपको ये
रहा नेक्स्ट थिंग इसके बाद एलस करता हूं
क्या आपको दिखाई दे रहे है कोई भी नहीं
दिखाई दे रहे अब इसको फाल t एक्टी के रन
कर दे रा रन कर दिया अब मैं एलस करके
दिखाता हूं देखो यहां पर क्रिएट हो गए
अकेडमी सोल्यूशन
हेलो वर्ल्ड नितेश सिंह सचिन और डे
फोनिक्स और आपको देखने को मिला हुआ एक और
अकेडमी हो गया डि फोनिक्स तो यह सारी इसने
ऑटोमेटिक स्क्रिप ने रन करके दिखा दी तो
आई होप आपका कांसेप्ट क्लियर हो एक और
सेक्शन कंप्लीट हो गया इसकी सेक्शन के बेस
पर जल्दी मैं मीडियम प एक आर्टिकल लिखता
हूं इसको भी कंप्लीट कर देता हूं इस
वीडियो इस साथ और फिर नेक्स्ट जो टॉपिक
हमारा मैं आपको सच बता हूं बैस का क्या है
ना डे 17 है डे 18 में इंटरेस्टिंग है और
डे 19 भी इंटरेस्टिंग रहेगा दो सेशन हैन
दो सेश में मैं क्या कर दूंगा ना आपका जो
बेसिक बैस है ना मतलब आपका बैस नियर
कंप्लीट हो गया नियर आपका बैस
स्क्रिप्टिंग कंप्लीट हो गया है जो बेस
समझाना था बेसिक ऑटोमेशन पार्ट बचा है जो
कैसे करते हम जिसम क्रोम जो वगैरह रहती है
उसके अलावा आपका जो कुछ अरे पार्ट बचा हुआ
और फोर लूप बचा हुआ है बाकी आपका बैस का
थोड़ा सा डीबगिंग भी बताऊंगा बट जो मैं
पांच प्रोजेक्ट की बात कर रहा था मैं करवा
सकता हूं बट यहां पर कोई रिस्पांस नहीं आ
रहा है को लोग यहां पर मेरे को हार्डली एक
वीडियो प 200 व्यू भी नहीं दे रहे हो यार
व्यू भीख मांग रहा हूं मैं आप लोगों से
नहीं मांग रहा 200 व्यू भी एक वीडियो दे
रहे तो मैं सिंपली बेस्ट स्क्रिप्टिंग को
कंप्लीट करूंगा आपके जो प्रोजेक्ट्स
हैं अगर मेरे पास स्ट्रेंथ नहीं है आप लोग
ऐसे रिस्पांस में है तो मेरी तरफ से ना य
समझना है मैं प्रोजेक्ट करवाऊंगी मैं जो
पांच प्रोजेक्ट की बोल रहा ना फुल
प्रोजेक्ट बेस में स्क्रिप्टिंग करवाने
वाला हूं तो मैं नहीं करवाऊं प्रोजेक्ट जो
मैं करवाने वाला हूं मैं तो यह भी सोचा था
कि आप लोगों में से 10 स्टूडेंट लूंगा और
10 स्टूडेंट को लेके हम मिलके क्या करेंगे
बैस का बैस के बेस पर हम एक बग बाउंट का
कोई भी एमेशन वाला या फुट प्रिंटिंग वाला
जो डीएनएस न्यूमरेशन करते हैं यह डीएनएस
जो सब डोमेन एन्यूमरेशन करते हैं सब डोमेन
फाइंड आउट करते हैं उसके बेस पर अच्छा सा
हम मिलके एक टूल डिजाइन करते उसको गिट पर
लंच करते ो की तरफ से बट नोबडी इंटरेस्टेड
तो नो
प्रॉब्लम मैं इंटरेस्ट ले रहा हूं तो मैं
बैस का जो एक कोर्स है वह कंप्लीट कर
दूंगा बट प्रोजेक्ट मैं भी नहीं करवाऊंगी
तो आप लोग पा मिनट आप लोग मुझसे कुछ भी
डाउट पूछ सकते हैं कुछ भी एनीथिंग रिलेटेड
टू बेस या अगर किसी को वैसे मुझसे बात
करनी है कि सर मुझे और भी कुछ से गाइडेंस
चाहिए अभी रिलेटेड टू एनी एथिकल हैकिंग या
शक से रिलेटेड कोई कोर्स में या किसी भी
भी जो प्रेजेंट है अगर वो पूछना चाहे तो
पूछ सकते हैं या कुछ भी अपडेशन जानना
चाहते जा सकते हैं जान सकते हैं दिस फ फर
य
ए बग बाउंट कोर्स जल्दी स्टार्ट होने वाला
डोंट वरी आपके नितेश सर ही लेंगे बगवां
कोस को मैं ले सकता था बट मैंने अभी मना
कर दिया सर को कि सर ही लेंगे इसको भगवां
टी कोर्स को क्योंकि ऑलरेडी मैं और कज यार
मैं वर्किंग
हूं और मैं इसलिए मुझे टाइम कम मिलता है
क्योंकि मेरी भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन मेरे को
छोड़ती नहीं
है मुझसे कुछ भी बोल सकते हैं
आप
फुल बग बांटी कोस
तो फलही रहेगा बट व भी डिपेंड करेगा कि आप
लोग रिस्पांस क्या है अगर आप लोग रिस्पांस
यही है सेम जैसा अब रिस्पांस है तो फिर आप
त सर को जानते हो कि वह कोर्स बंद करने
में टाइम नहीं
लगाएंगे हम या जितनी मेहनत करते हैं आप
लोगों
को शायद ही कोई करता होगा शायद ही कोई इस
तरीके से आपको कंटेंट प्रोवाइड करेगा कोई
बात नहीं वन डे आपको हमारी इस कंटेंट की
वैल्यू पता चलेगा हमारा तो चैनल बंद नहीं
होने वाला डोंट वरी बट आप लोगों को सब कुछ
ही आता है बता क्या है ना कि आप लोग सोचते
हो कि बग बांटी ही सब कुछ है बग बांटी ही
बस एक हैकिंग है अगर बग बांटी आ गई तो सब
कुछ आ गया मैं अगर आपको सच बोलू ना तो बग
बांटी इज
नथिंग बग बाउटी इज
नथिंग अब आप लोग बग बाउंट ही क्यों कर रहे
हो लोग को लगता है कि मैं बग फाइंड आउट
करूंगा और मैं मेरे को पैसे
मिलेंगे
बस देखो पैसे केलिए सब लेकिन बग बाउंट ही
मैं बताता हूं बग बाउटी सब कुछ नहीं है एक
बग बाउंट में सब वे वस्ट ऑफ 10 सीखते हो
आप जो ओनली वेबसाइट के लिए वेबसाइट की
टेस्टिंग के लिए
तो आप अगर अच्छे डेवलपर हो ना मैं बोलता
अगर आपको अच्छी खासी नॉलेज थोड़ी बहुत अगर
कोडिंग आती है जैसे कि जावास्क्रिप्ट
एक्सल य एचटीएमएल सीएसएस और पीएचपी नोट
जेएस तो जाइए बग माउंटी के लिए डेफिनेटली
क्योंकि आपको चीज बेटर समझ में आएंगी
बेहतर तरीके से समझ में आएंगी क्यक अभी बग
माउंटी का लेवल बदल गया थोड़ा सा लेवल
इसलिए बदल गया
क्योंकि अब वल्नरेबल है ना है
लेकिन टिपिकल
ढूंढनी ऐसा नहीं कि वल्नरेबल नहीं है
वेबसाइट वेबसाइट वल्नरेबल है ब तरीके बदल
गए हैं वेब 3.0 आ गया है ब्लॉक चन के
ऊपर अभी तो वेब 3.0 आ गया 2.0 ही सीख रहे
हो 3.0 आ गया उसके लिए ब्लॉक चन सीखनी
पड़ेगी उसका तरीका अलग बदल
जाएगा जज्बात भावनाए बदल जाएंगे आप लोगों
के टीसीपी थ इंप्लीमेंट हो गया अभी तो
टीसीपी ट चल रहा है थ का तो नाम नाम चल
रहा है अगर ढंग से टीसीपी 3 इंप्लीमेंट हो
गया तो आपका बब सूट जो प्रॉक्सीस है ना व
काम करना बंद कर
जाएंगे बब सूट कहां से यूज करोगे ज
प्रोक्सी बब सूट ही काम नहीं
करेंगे क्योंकि इंडिया में 3 सप 3.0
स्पोर्टेड है लेकिन पूरी तरह से
इंप्लीमेंट नहीं हुआ
है कभी किसी ने बब शूट को उसके ऊपर करके
देखा है क्रम पे कम हमेशा किस पर करते हो
फायरफॉक्स प यूज करते हो ब सूट को कम पर
क्यों नहीं करते अब क्विक प्रोटोकॉल यूज
होता
है व क्या करता
है व एक प्रकार से टीसीपी थ की तरह ही काम
करता है व आपको बब सट जैसी चीजों को अलाउड
ही नहीं करता प्रोक्सी आप यूज ही नहीं कर
सकते इसलिए आप सबसे ज्यादा प्रायोरिटी
किसको देते हो firefox.exe
के अलावा न प्रिविलेज एलेशन
भैया भगवां का पार्ट नहीं है वो विंडोज
प्रिविलेज एलेशन भगवां का पार्ट नहीं
है समझे एंड्राइड हैकिंग बगवां का पार्ट
नहीं है
एपीआई एपीआई फ्यूचर बहुत सही है साइबर
सिक्योरिटी है ब्रो बहुत सही है तो वो
सारी चीजें है आईओटी
हैकिंग आईओटी पेन
टेस्टिंग वीआईपी
हैकिंग ये तो क्या है ना कि डिफेंसिव साइड
है ना बहुत ऐसी चीजें हैं हम सब एक वर्ड
को सुनते आए हैं कि बग बाउटी बग बाउटी बग
बाउटी
बस गुड बग बाउटी करो बट पेंटेस्टिंग में
जब बात है ना आप एक स्कोप लिमिट कर रहे हो
अपना वेब पन टेस्टिंग में बस
ओनली स्कोप को क्या ना अगर आपको नहीं है
अगर आपको लगता है कि मुझे कुछ करना है फॉर
एग्जांपल मुझे क्या करना है मैं एक बार
इसको स्क्रीन देता हूं फर एग्जांपल अगर
मुझे आपको लगता है कि आपको ओससीपी देना है
ईजी पीटी देना है उसके बाद साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में जॉब करनी है तो एक बग
बाउंट से आपकी साइबर सिक्योरिटी जॉब नहीं
लगेगी वेब पन टेस्टिंग में आप जा सकते हो
फिल्ड में जा सकते हो वेब पन टेस्टिंग में
वेबसाइट टेस्टिंग कर सकते हो वहां पर जॉब
मिल जाएगा स्कोप है बट एक्चुअल में पन
टेस्टिंग बहुत बड़ा है हर एक हर एक पार्ट
प पन टेस्टिंग है क्लाउड पन टेस्टिंग एड्स
की आ जाती है पन टेस्टिंग यह तो मैं आपको
ना रेड टीमिंग बता रहा
हूं अगर आप डिफेंसिव साइड पढ़ोगे ना ब्लू
टीमिंग
तो जो ब्लू टीमिंग पोगे ना तो आपके नहीं
है आपको मजा आएगा चीजों को समझने में ब्लू
ट मिंग ज्यादा इंटरेस्टेड है इससे रेड
टीमिंग से कुछ लोगों को अच्छी लगती कुछ
लोगों को नहीं लगती क्योंकि क्या होता है
देखो जब आप रेड टीमिंग पढ़ के जाते हो ना
रेड टीमिंग वाली चीज अटैक करने सीख के जब
उसको डिफेंस करोगे ना आपको पता चल रहा
होता है कि जब मैं अटैक कर रहा था तो
डिफेंसिव साइड में नहीं
है मैं कैसे देख सकता हूं उसको अगर मैंने
डोस किया है डिफेंसिव सर्ड को कैसे
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
भैया इंडस्ट्री कैसे काम करती
है ओके इंडस्ट्री कैसे काम करती है वो चीज
समझनी होगी लिमिटेड मत बनो मेरे भाई
लिमिटेड मत बनो मैं आपको बता रहा
हूं जरूरी है और एक बार डिफेंसिव साइड सीख
लिया तो आपको नहीं है फिर पता चल जाएगा
मुझे करना क्या है क्योंकि एक बार नहीं
ट्राई करो दोनों
अटैक डिफेंसिव और ऑफेंसिव दोनों
सीखो जो हमारे पास अवेलेबल
है जो हमारे पास अवेलेबल
है अटैकिंग और डिफेंसिव दोनों ही सीखो
उसके बाद क्या करो आप फिर देखो कोई भी
इंटरव्यू दो सब कुछ
दो हाउ टू मेक मनी विदाउट सर्टिफिकेशन इन
साइबर सिक्योरिटी भाई
देखो पैसा बनाना इतना भी आसान नहीं है
जितना आप बोल रहे
हो या तो चोरी करना सीख सकते हो हैकिंग मी
वन वे बट आई विल नॉट
सजेस्ट नेवर सजेस्ट करियर बर्बाद हो जाएगा
जिंदगी खराब हो जाएगी कोई नहीं
बचाएगा सीधी सी बात है कुछ पैसों के लिए
लाइफ खराब कर लोगे अपनी दि नॉट गुड वे
सबसे अच्छा तरीका है अपनी एजुकेशन कंप्लीट
करो और उस एजुकेशन के साथ अपना जो
एक्स्ट्रा कैलकुलस है ये एक्स्ट्रा में
आते
हैं बस नीड हो गी इंडस्ट्री की अभी चीजें
बदल गई है इतनी जॉब्स निकलती है लेकिन
बिकॉज ऑफ द स्किल आप मार खा जाते हो आपको
पता ही नहीं कि मुझे करना क्या है हमें
सिर्फ क्या है कि टूल्स यूज भी नहीं करने
आते सिर्फ टूल्स का नाम सुना है और हमें
कोई क्लास में पढ़ाता भी है ना तो उस
टूल्स को हम सिंपली क्या करते हैं कि
देखते हैं और उसका जो जितना पढ़ाया उतना
ही परफॉर्म करेंगे उसके ऊपर देन उसके बाद
खुद से उस पर कोई रिसर्च नहीं करेंगे कि
वो काम कैसे करता बिहाइंड द सिनेरियो क्या
है और मैं काम क्या करने वाला हूं किस
टाइप से मैं अटैक करने वाला हूं क्यों कर
रहा
हूं और क्यों जरूरत पड़ी मुझे करने की यह
वनटी मुझे क्यों मिली इस वनटी से मैं क्या
क्या कर सकता हूं नेक्स्ट स्टेप मेरा क्या
रहेगा इवन हमें नहीं पता रहे
क्योंकि हम लिमिटेड खु खुद से लिमिटेड हो
रुके
हैं खुद को अपने आप में लिमिट कर चुके
हैं समझे तो अच्छी एजुकेशन लीजिए अच्छे से
ग्रेजुएशन कंप्लीट कीजिए और ग्रेजुएशन के
साथ-साथ बेटर सर्टिफिकेशन में आपको बताऊं
तो ईजी पटी अच्छा सर्टिफिकेशन
है सबसे बेस्ट सर्टिफिकेशन है
और रियलिस्टिक
सर्टिफिकेशन गो फॉर इट अपना उसको ट्राई
कीजिए उसकी वैल्यू
एग्जाम की और ऐसा कुछ सर्टिफिकेशन हम
डिजाइन कर रहे
हैं उतना उस लेवल का नहीं उस लेवल का भी
हम डिजाइन कर देंगे बट उससे थोड़ा सा लो
लेवल बट क्या आप उसके बाद क्या कि उस पर
आप आसानी से शिफ्ट कर पाओगे और उसको ट्राई
कर सकते हो देन कुछ सोर्सेस पढ़ने के बाद
उसके बाद ओसीपी जा सकते हो द बेटर ऑप्शन
उसके लिए आपको डायरेक्टरी पढ़नी होगी और
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी पढ़ने के लिए मैं तो
अगर मैं आपको एक अच्छी अप्रोच बताऊं एक
अच्छा सजेशन दूं मैं आपको तो अच्छा सजेशन
यह रहेगा कि आप लोग क्या करो ना
कि आपको माइक्रोसॉफ्ट सर्वर की नॉलेज ले
लो एक बार मैं नहीं बोलता मास्टर बन
जाओ बस उसकी नॉलेज ले लो कि एक्चुअल में
इंडस्ट्री में काम कैसे होता है जैसे हम
विंडो मशीन अभी लेकर बैठे है ना इंडस्ट्री
में ऐसे काम नहीं होता व ऐसे काम ही नहीं
करते तो अगर आपको इंडस्ट्री का वर्किंग
कल्चर नहीं
पता अगर आपको इंडस्ट्री का वर्किंग कल्चर
नहीं मालूम तो पन टेस्टिंग किसके खिलाफ
करोगे क्योंकि इंडस्ट्री कैसे काम करती है
एक्टू डायरेक्टरी पर शिफ्ट हो चुकी
है तो एटलीस्ट अगर आपको लिनक्स सर्वर और
विंडो सर्वर दोनों को एक बार गो थ्रू कर
लिया
नोट्स है पता चल गया कि कैसे कन्फेशन होते
हैं एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी कैसे कन्फेशन होती
है उसके बाद उसका बैकअप कैसे बनता है चाइल
डोमेन कंट्रोलर कैसे बनते हैं एडीसी कैसे
बनती है पीडीसी कैसे बनते हैं उसके बाद
उसके अंदर ग्रुप पॉलिसी कैसे लगती है उसके
बाद बहुत सारी चीजें
हैं कैसे क्या कुछ नहीं है बिल्कुल सेम ट
हमारी विंडो जैसे ही पर काम करने का थोड़
तरीका अलग है उनका उसके बाद वो कैसे
प्रोटेक्ट करते हैं अपने आप को एक बार यह
नॉलेज आपको मैं नहीं बोल रहा कि आप जाओ और
मास्टर बन जाओ उसमें नहीं एटलीस्ट एक बार
नहीं इसका कोर्स कहीं से भी नहीं है अगर
आपको अटेंड करने को मिल रहा है ना अटेंड
करो बस सीखो अगर खुद से सामने है एक बार
उसको परफॉर्म करके देख लो कि ओके ओके
क्योंकि सारा विंडो सर्वर और लिनक्स सर्वर
दोनों ही दोनों 90 पर प्रैक्टिकल कोर्सेस
है ये ये एक बार परफॉर्म कर लिए ना और
उसके नोट्स रख लो कोई भी पीपीटी से दे
पीपीटी लेकर रख लो विंडोज में तो आपको
क्या है ना कभी नोट्स बनाने की जरूरत ही
नहीं क्योंकि जब विंडोज पर अगर विंडो
सर्वर पढ़ रहे होंगे ना आपको कभी भी नोट्स
बनाने की जरूरत नहीं है हमेशा बस आपको
क्या करना है बस उसको प्रैक्टिकल परफॉर्म
करके देखना है और आपका काम बन जाएगा आपका
काम बन जाएगा विंडोज क्योंकि ग्राफिकल है
ग्राफिकल में एक बार जो आपने परफॉर्म कर
हमेशा याद रहेगा तो वो एक बार सीख लोगे
उसके बाद एक बार नक् को निकाल लो नेटवर्क
कैसे कन्फर कर
डिस्क मैनेजमेंट कैसे कर पाओगे और उसकी
सिक्योरिटी कैसे काम करती थोड़ी उसकी
हार्ड निंग सीख लो ताकि खुद को भी बचा लो
और पन टेस्ट भी अच्छे से कर पाओ एक अच्छे
पैन टेस्टर बन
पाओ सीखने के लिए बहुत कुछ है री लाइफ
सीखते रहो डेली नई वनटी आती है डेली सब
कुछ नया नया आता
है तो आपको आपको पास सीखने के लिए बहुत
कुछ है
जब अगर ब्लू टीमिंग के सर्टिफिकेशन में
जाना चाहो तो वो भी मेरे पास पता है उसका
पाथ क्या है तो मुझे लगता सभी छोड़ के चले
गए और बोर हो
ग ड एनी वन हैव
लिसनिंग ठी देखते कितने लोग बचे हैं अभी
अगर किसी को कुछ पूछना है अगर बात करनी तो
कर सकता
है कोई भी अगर तो बात कर सकता मुझसे अभी
कुछ भी पूछ सकता है स इन्वेस्टिगेशन सीखना
है तो इन्वेस्टिगेशन आपको शक में ही सीखने
को मिल सकता
है सोक एनालिस्ट है ना उसम इन्वेस्टिगेशन
सीखने को मिलता
है एसआई एम टूल्स है वह सीख
लोगे
सोर डिजिटल
फॉरेंसिक
एनालिसिस
यह सब उसमें आते हैं ब्लू टीमिंग
सर्टिफिकेशन
में साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन
प्रैक्टिकल्स कोई नहीं दिखाएगा कभी भी कोई
भी नहीं
दिखाएगा कोई भी नहीं दिखाएगा आपको और जिसे
सीखने जाओगे
ना आपकी हिम्मत नहीं होगी पैसे खरीदने की
पैस कोर्स खरीदने की पर मिलेंगे मिल
जाएंगे नो
गारंटी कि वह आपको लूटेंगे या सच में सिखा
देंगे क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन वही है कैसे
करोगे क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन होता क्या भाई
सीधी सी बात में एक छोटा सा लॉजिक है एक
सवाल आप लो आपसे ही है मेरा कि क्राइम
साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन कैसे कर सकते
हो कि अटैक हो गया कैसे परफॉर्म
करोगे आपका सवाल का मैक्सिमम आपको अगर
जवाब बताऊ ना आपका ब्लू टीमिंग
में ब्लू टीमिंग में आपका जवाब है अगर
ब्लू टीमिंग सर्टिफिकेशन करते हो ना ब्लू
टीमिंग की तरफ अगर बढ़ते भी हो प्राइम
यस्ट के क्यों हुआ कि सिस्टम में वलन
बिलिटी थी किसी ने हैक किया वह सिस्टम में
बैठ गया और सिस्टम में अगर वह बैठ गया तो
उसको ढूंढना होता
है जल्दी से जल्दी वही इन्वेस्टिगेशन हो
गया क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन साइबर क्राइम वो
भी क्राइम ही है अ किसीने चोरी की है व की
है तो भैया फिर आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा यली
ओसेंट का यूज करना पड़ेगा अच्छे आप ओसेंट
बनो आपको अच्छे खासे नॉलेज हो फिसिंग की
मैनिपुलेट कर पाओ फोन पर ही और उसके बाद
फिर हर चीज की नॉलेज होनी
चाहिए बाकी अदर वाइज तो सबसे बेटर नॉलेज
अगर आपको बोलू तो फिर इफ यू हैव द
कैपेबिलिटी तो अगर इ पॉसिबल
तो
किसी ऐसी र् में जा सके जहा पर जैसे पुलिस
के साथ जुड़ने का मौका मिले क्राइम
इन्वेस्टिगेशन करने में कोई दोस्त
हो वो और भी ज्यादा बेटर सजेशन दे सकते
हैं बट अगर कंपनी का कोई इन्वेस्टिगेशन
करवाना हो कंपनी का अगर जैसे कि एनालिसिस
कैसे होता है कंपनी एलिस कैसे करती है व
बता सकता
हूं साइबर क्राइम इन्वेस्टिगेशन भी साइबर
क्राइम भी वही होता है साइबर क्राम वही है
जिसने क्या कर दिया किसी के साथ मलिस करने
की कोशिश करी इंटेंशन गलत था वही साइबर
क्राइम है एनी अदर
क्वेश्चन एनी
वन किसी को कुछ भी पूछना पूछ सकता है अगर
आप लोगों तो मीट अप रख सकता हूं एक दिन
बोलोगे तो कल तो नहीं रख सकता फिर संडे आई
थिंक मुझे एक मीट रखना चाहिए आप लोग के
साथ
कोई है
जो
सेशन को एंड करते हैं फिर
भाई
ओके फर सेशन को एंड करते हैं आज थैंक यू
बाय बाय टेक केयर सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन
प्लीज आना मत भूलिए आप लोगों को अच्छा लगा
है मेरे गाइडेंस अच्छी लगी तो थोड़ा सा
मुझे कंट्रीब्यूट कीजिए एंड सी यू बाय बाय
टेक केयर गुड
नाइट